[Musica]
Buonasera
guardate in alto oggi Vorrei che
guardassimo tutti in alto Cosa vedete
un'immagine familiare Non a cui siamo
abituati Fin dall'infanzia
un cielo pieno di stelle
appoggiate su uno sfondo blu scuro
piatto quasi un soffitto Ma cos'è che
stiamo davvero guardando Quali sono i
limiti di questo che noi chiamiamo cielo
vorrei che lo scoprissimo insieme oggi
questa sera in questo percorso e vorrei
che facessimo all'inizio un percorso
tutti insieme allora proviamo a chiudere
gli occhi dico sul serio proviamo a
chiuderli per un istante e cercate di
immaginare quella che per voi è la cosa
più distante che fa parte della vostra
realtà quella cosa con cui è entrata in
contatto tutti i giorni e che sentite
far parte della vostra esistenza della
vostra quotidianità Ecco adesso riaprite
gli occhi l'immagine che vedete alle mie
spalle è esattamente il cielo che
vediamo sopra di noi qui a Castelfranco
da questa platea Ecco è Quella striscia
magnifica striscia luminosa che vedete a
fendere il cielo è il braccio della
nostra galassia che si congiunge nel suo
centro ancora più luminoso in basso a
destra il centro della nostra galassia
distante 25.000 anni luce da noi e
Questa immagine è reale quello che
potremmo vedere qui oggi ad occhio nudo
se solo per un istante potessimo
spegnere tutte quelle luci che vengono
intrappolate nell'atmosfera
l'inquinamento luminoso ma anche la luce
che proviene dalle stelle e quindi
questa Galassia è per noi reale ed è
reale ci appartiene tanto quanto ci
appartengono le montagne i cui profili
possiamo vedere nelle giornate perse e
questo non dobbiamo dimenticarlo e
stasera vorrei che
potesse condividere con me quello che è
la mia visione di realtà dei suoi limiti
spaziali e dei suoi limiti temporali io
questa visione diciamo l'acquisita
attraverso i miei studi ma penso che
faccia parte della quotidianità di tutti
noi
quando noi cerchiamo di pensare a nostra
realtà la nostra quotidianità tendiamo
porni limite spaziali al massimo 1-2
oceani di distanza per esempio lì dove
abita il nostro amico che abbiamo
conosciuto in Erasmus oppure in quel bel
posto esotico dove tanto ci piacerebbe
andare in vacanza e se pensiamo ai
limiti temporali Beh allora Grazie hai
tantissimi reperti archeologici che
possiamo trovare disseminati sul nostro
pianeta siamo in grado di catapultarci
nelle diverse epoche dell'evoluzione
umana o ancora quando ci soffermiamo a
guardare le rocce delle nostre montagne
del nostro favoloso Dolomiti per esempio
e con un Colpo d'occhio possiamo
apprezzare tutti gli strati che
ricordano queste rocce Beh noi con un
Colpo d'occhio stiamo ripercorrendo le
diverse R geologiche del nostro pianeta
questo per quanto mi riguarda già di per
sé è stupendo ma sono questi limiti
della nostra realtà del nostro spazio
del nostro tempo possiamo andare oltre
Sì possiamo andare oltre e l'unica cosa
che dobbiamo fare per spingerci ai
nostri limiti e seguire la luce la luce
Lo sappiamo tutti è un'onda che si
propaga nello spazio in maniera
indefinita almeno fino a incontrare un
ostacolo a velocità costante Questo vuol
dire che se scegliessimo un punto a
nostro Orizzonte abbastanza vuoto
contassimo una torcia Beh noi in linea
di principio potremmo raggiungere un
punto infinitamente lontano
dall'universo L'unica cosa che dobbiamo
fare è avere la pazienza di aspettare
che la luce abbia il tempo di
raggiungere questi punti lontani
viceversa noi oggi in questo momento
possiamo
ricevere la luce proveniente da punti
lontanissimi da noi dell'universo
talmente lontani quanto lo spazio che la
luce può percorrere nell'intero tempo
pari all'età dell'universo
in più però la luce ha un'altra
particolarità essa è intimamente legata
alle trame dell'universo e grazie a
questo essa conserva la memoria del suo
viaggio ma cerchiamo di capire come
ormai è cosa nota che il nostro universo
si sta espandendo possiamo ad esempio
pensarlo come la superficie di un
palloncino sul quale possiamo disegnare
una griglia e su questa griglia dei
punti
noi su questo universo siamo come una
cimice che può vedere soltanto la
superficie del palloncino non esiste
dentro non esiste fuori Allora mentre
l'universo evolve esso si espande come
un palloncino che si gonfia per noi che
siamo oggetti pesanti Noi non sentiamo
queste espansioni rimaniamo gli stessi
al contrario Cosa succede quando
gonfiamo il palloncino le trame della
griglia si espandono e i punti su questa
griglia si allontanano sempre di più da
noi noi non possiamo farci niente solo
vederli allontanare Ma a differenza di
noi la luce
sente questa espansiones è legata
all'universo è obbligata a seguirne
l'espansione E quindi cosa succede che
nel suo viaggio da una galassia lontana
a noi essa è obbligata a metterci sempre
lo stesso tempo per percorrere la
distanza che separa un punto della
griglia dal successivo come la
conseguenza la lunghezza d'onda che è la
quantità che descrive il colore per
esempio e qui è rappresentata
pittoricamente da quei due punti rossi
nel grafico ad onda del della luce
mentre la luce si espande mentre Luce
arriva a noi e l'universo si espande
essa anch'essa si dilata Si espanda si
allunga passatemi il termine non molto
preciso e quindi la sua lunghezza d'onda
cambia il suo colore cambia Ma allora se
ad esempio
possessivo pensare di vedere una torcia
di colore giallo Che punta verso di noi
da una distanza molto lontano l'universo
Ecco nel tempo in cui la luce arriva a
noi il suo colore Cambia Cambia sempre
di più verso l'arancione vado verso il
rosso e poi
lo possiamo vedere più perché noi come
umani il nostro occhio della luce può
vedere soltanto una piccola porzione
quello che è il visibile quelli che sono
i colori e quindi quella Galassia per
noi ha persa non la vediamo più ma non è
perché noi non vediamo le cose che se
non esistono pensiamo alla TV in questo
momento penso nessuno di noi sia in
grado di vedere ad occhio nudo
l'immagine televisiva Eppure Se
mettessimo con un'antenna un televisore
Voilà le immagini della televisione
Dobbiamo quindi solo sapere come
guardare quindi allo stesso tempo che
per la TV possiamo costruire delle
antenne dei telescopi e riappropriarci
dell'universo che non vedevamo più ad
esempio possiamo guardare oggetti
lontanissimi nel tempo nello spazio e
spingerci nelle microonde luce con
lunghezza d'onda molto lunga oppure
andare a vedere quegli oggetti che di
per sé avevano un colore che avremmo
potuto vedere Non sono molto lontani ma
magari erano già sul rosso e quella poca
distanza fatto sì che con l'espansione
verso le perdessimo Questa è l'immagine
ha infrarosso questa immagine che ci
proviene da un nuovo esperimento
James Webb che è stato rilasciato
martedì questo martedì E ci descrive la
morte di due stelle di una coppia di due
stelle possiamo anche vedere ciò che è
visibile senza grande sforzo ma comunque
bellissimo qui cinque galassie che
interagiscono Oppure visto che già ci
siamo possiamo andare anche a vedere
quelle luci che noi mai avremmo potuto
vedere ad esempio i raggi gamma Ma
allora facciamolo questo sforzo e
andiamo lì ai limiti di quelle che sono
le capacità della nostra luce nelle
microonde e guardiamoci intorno non c'è
tanta interferenza Non è difficile cosa
vediamo questo questa immagine Magari
adesso non mi dice molto bene questa è
l'immagine dell'universo primordiale in
questo momento l'universo verrà fatto
soltanto da molecole di idrogeno e
questa è la prima luce dopo il big bang
che è riuscita a scappare da quel plasma
caldo che era l'universo mondiale e
aggiungere fino a noi i diversi colori
che vedete in questa immagine descrivono
e tracciano le diverse concentrazioni di
queste molecole di idrogeno in queste
concentrazioni che andranno via via ad
accrescersi si formeranno le prime
stelle lì le prime galassie lì Noi
questa è la nostra culla Questo è il
nostro passato
Ma allora seguiamo la luce e cerchiamo
di colmare quella distanza che separa
noi con l'inizio dell'universo
e per farlo come abbiamo detto facciamo
questo esperimento di prendere una
torcia e cercare un punto vuoto
all'orizzonte in cui possiamo osservare
adesso non sembra ma un grasso molto
affollato quindi per farlo dobbiamo
andare a cercare una zona molto molto
piccola tra le miriade infinita di
stelle e ci mettiamo lì fissi ed
osserviamo Questo è quello che è stato
fatto puntando una telecamera per 11
giorni consecutivi dall'esperimento
Hubble nel 2003 e Questa che vedete
apparire adesso è l'immagine due
dimensionale un quadro che siamo potuti
che siamo riusciti a ricevere Qui ci
sono 10.000 galassie di vario tipo
possiamo riconoscere delle Galassi a
spirale per esempio sono simili a noi
sono Galassi antiche Oppure delle
macchie di luce sono dalla sellittiche
galassie giovani oppure altre strutture
di diversa forma irregolare
bello ma cosa ci dicono questa classe
quando sono state fotografate dove sono
Ricordiamoci che se noi sappiamo
guardare la luce sappiamo misurare la
dilatazione di questa lunghezza d'onda
che è dovuta alla dilatazione dello
spazio possiamo riuscire a risalire da
dove viene la nostra immagine e anche
quando è stata emessa quando parliamo di
Universo tempo spazio sono la stessa
cosa se è lontano allora indietro nel
tempo perché stiamo aspettando i tempi
della luce non i nostri
ricordatelo Non siamo più liberi di
fissare un tempo e muoverci nello spazio
come facciamo nella quotidianità ma
questo comunque ci permette di costruire
un universo tridimensionale di nuovo
quello a cui siamo abituati e questo
universo si estende per 13 miliardi di
anni 13 miliardi di anni qui l'età della
prima immagine che avete visto
all'inizio
del nostro universo Ma allora iniziamo
il nostro viaggio all'interno di questo
universo adesso
siamo vicini a noi e l'immagine è
relativamente recente vediamo galassia
spirale Galassia ellittiche una
moltitudine Una varietà di diverse
galassie più ci allontaniamo più le
forme diventano irregolari Le spirali
sempre di meno vediamo che invece queste
classi ellittiche queste macchie di
colore iniziano ad essere dominanti nel
nostro universo e noi continuiamo a
muoverci vediamo queste ammassi di gas
che non riusciamo ancora a capire e poi
ci spostiamo più vediamo soltanto dei
punti diventano sempre più rari sempre
più rari fino ad arrivare qui Questa è
la galassia più distante che possiamo
vedere 12 miliardi di anni fa e ne
vediamo solo il centro ma non perché non
siamo in grado di vedere perché a
quell'epoca soltanto il centro sia era
formato
Ecco noi adesso vorremmo capire cosa
succederà questa stella No è normale ci
chiediamo sempre cosa succede come Cosa
è successo a noi per capirlo possiamo
tornare verso di noi tornare vicino
tornare vicino nel tempo Ok allora
facciamolo questo viaggio
riavviciniamoci a noi
iniziamo a muoverci verso la moltitudine
di galassie Ed ecco che incontriamo un
insieme di queste galassie Infatti le
galassie tendono ad avvicinarsi a
interagire fra loro scambiarsi materia
fino a fondersi in un unico oggetto
questo oggetto poi continuerà a ruotare
ruotare ruotare si stabilizzerà Dopo
miliardi di anni darà forma a una
bellissima Grazia spirale come noi molto
simile a noi e quindi quello che noi
possiamo fare oggi guardando la luce che
vediamo oggi con i nostri occhi e
ricostruire quella che è l'evoluzione
delle galassie distanti che dal luogo
poi a Galassi che sono simili a noi e
quindi possiamo immaginare possiamo
sognare Qual è la nostra storia
E allora oggi vorrei lasciarvi con un
invito torniamo tutti a guardare in alto
non smettiamo mai di guardare in alto
perché lì sopra le nostre teste il
nostro Orizzonte può arrivare ad
accarezzare le origini dell'universo
tutto quello che dobbiamo fare è
semplicemente sapere come metterci
controluce Grazie
[Applauso]